ininformations, les rendre
didisponibles pour que les gens
pupuissent décider pour leur
fafamille.
- - Regardant le taux de
vavaccination au Canada :
esest-ce que vous pensez que ce
tataux est un bon taux de
vavaccination et est-ce qu'il ns
pepermet d'aborder l'idée qu'on
amamorce un tournant et on aura
unune nouvelle approche?
- - Le taux de vaccination est
cecertainement très bon, on se
sisitue parmi les meilleurs. Il
fafaut aller plus loin, parce qe
l'l'immunité collective, on ne
pepeut la voir que par la
vavaccination ou l'infection.
CoComme on a déjà entendu, mieux
vavaut et de loin avoir le vaccn
àà l'infection. Il faut vraiment
dodoubler d'efforts pour vaccinr
totout le monde, incluant les
enenfants. Là-dessus j'aimerais
pepeut-être juste rajouter que e
ququi fait peur aux parents pour
leles enfants de moins de 12 an,
c'c'est la myocardite et d'autre
papart le fait que ce soit un
vavaccin à ARN messager. Je
vovoudrais vous dire que pour ls
mymyocardites, le risque d'avoir
unune myocardite si on est infeé
esest de sept à 10 fois plus
élélevées question dans le vacc.
LaLa deuxième chose, c'est que
l'l'ARN messager, c'est vraiment
unune molécule qui est très
ininstable et à partir du moment
ouoù elle est dans la cellule et
ququ'elle a produit la protéine,
elelle va être dégradée donc ele
didisparaît très rapidement.
J'J'aimerais encourager les
adadultes et les enfants à être
vavacciné.
- - Il n'y a pas de vaccin conte
lala désinformation mais il y a
enencore un bout de chemin à fae
dede ce côté-là, même du côté de
lala recherche de nouveaux
vavaccins.
- - AuCanada, on est très bien
vavacciné. Il y a eu peut-être a
vivitesse d'administration de la
trtroisième dose, peut-être plus
auau Québec que dans d'autres
prprovinces mais on s'adapte. Le
vavaccin ARN, c'est un gââteauùu
onon peut modifier la recette
rarapidement il suffit de modifr
lala recette pour avoir une
nonouvelle version améliorée. Ls
vavaccins ARN, c'est mieux
d'd'attraper un vaccin ARN avecn
totout petit morceau d'ARN du
vivirus que le virus au complet,
paparce que vous allez avoir
totoutes les formes d'ARN du
vivirus. La vaccination, il y a
ilil y a 9,7 milliards de dosese
vavaccins qui ont été donnés
momonde. Jamais dans l'histoiree
l'l'humanité on a donné autant e
vavaccin aussi rapidement à autt
dede monde. Des fois les vaccins
onon les donne aux enfants, aux
pepersonnes âgées. Là, on les a
dodonnés à tout le monde et on a
pupu évaluer la sécurité du vacn
susur des milliards de personnes
dadans tous les groupes d'âges
papartout sur la planète, des
hohommes, des femmes, plus jeune
etet plus vieux. Toutes les étus
popointent dans la même directi.
LeLes avantages de la vaccccinan
l'l'emportent très nettement sur
leles problèmes potentiels. On
vovoit malheureusement des gens
nonon vaccinés relativement jeus
trtrès malades, parfois aux sois
inintensifs. On n'en discutera
prprobablement et on pourra parr
dede six microns est moins sévèe
quque le reste. Quand ça affecte
dedes gens non vaccinés, on voit
enencore des maladies sévères.
- - En tant que pédiatre, est-ce
quque vous avez vu des cas de ts
jejeunes enfants très malades? l
y y a des cas qui ont été
rarapportés dans le New York Tis
dede médecins qui disaient qu'is
aiaient de très jeunes patients
ququi s'inquiétaient. Il n'y a s
nénécessairement eu d'études là-
dedessus, mais quel est votre
réréflexion?
- - Un peu comme les autres virs
rerespiratoires, longeant l'enft
ââgé de moins de six mois qui et
exexposé et qui développe une
COCOVID de façon précoce peut êe
rerelativement malade avec des
prproblèmes respiratoires aux
sosoins intensifs. C'est vraimet
cecette population le plus à
ririsque de développer des
cocomplications respiratoires,
d'd'où l'importance de vacciner
leles mères enceintes et limiter
lala transmission intra familia.
- - Il y a eu un essai cliniquee
PfPfizer BioNTech avec les enfas
dede moins de cinq ans et on s't
rerendu compte que le vaccin ne
auaugmentait pas les anticorps
prprotecteurs. Qu'est-ce que ça
veveut dire? Peut-être ce vaccin
l'l'homme ne pourra pas
fofonctionner auprès des tout-
pepetits?
- - C'est le nombre de doses
nénécessaires, quand on comparee
nonombre de doses nécessaires cz
unun très jeune enfant par rappt
àà pluvieux, ça prend parfois
plplus de vaccin dans la dose
prprimaire. Est-ce que ce sera e
dodosage qui sera différent? One
pepeut pas conclure sur ses
rérésultats tant qu'on ne les a
papas eus.
- - Quand on entend l'OMS déclae
ququ'il faut faire attention, on
nonous met en garde contre laa
tetentation de comparer ce qui e
papasse actuellement à un rhume.
VoVotre réaction à ça? Bien des
gegens vont dire : pourquoi je e
fafais vacciner, c'est juste un
rhrhume. Même les vaccinés sont
mamalades.
- - J'étais à l'hôpital
auaujourd'hui et j'ai vu trois e
memes patients qui étaient
rerelativement immuno supprimait
àà son entrée à l'hôpital pour
unune autre raison, testé négatf
àà l'entrée et deux jours plus
tatard tests positifs et 24 heus
apaprès aux soins intensifs. Por
ceceux qui pensent comme micron
esest juste un rhume, c'est fau.
IlIl faut enlever ça de la tête.
OmOmicron peut causer des malads
auaussi graves que Delta, et c't
paparticulièrement vrai chez les
nonoms vaccinés.
QuQuelqu'un qui est immuno
cocompromis, c'est une soeur qua
eueu un cancer du sang et qui au
dede la chimiothérapie, un oncle
avavec un cancer du pancréas qui
susuit des traitements, quelqu'n
ququi est VIH. On connaît tous s
gegens dans notre entourage, ces
gegens-là, il faut les protéger.
SiSi c'est pas une motivation
pepersonnelle qui va faire en
sosorte que les gens vont aller
chchercher leur troisième dose,e
pepense qu'il faut penser à ces
gegens qui seront les premières
vivictimes de cette vague.
- - Une question : est-ce qu'ily
a a de la COVID de longue chez s
enenfants?
- - Si o on regarde les études
jujusqu'à maintenant, des sondas
ququi demandent des questions ax
paparents et aux enfants, il y a
auautour de deux à 4 %. Quand
cocompare ça une population témn
ququi n'a pas eu la COVID-19, ls
popourcentages rapportés sont à
pepeu près similaires, donc c'et
àà se demander si la COVID langu